it's really an honor for me to be back
in Connecticut with you here today so
thank you for the invitation it's an
honor to be representing the president's
hurricane sandy task force I grew up in
mystic and willimantic and my father is
a proud graduate of the Yale class of
nineteen forty one so thank you for
having me here and thank you senator
Murphy for the invitation we're coming
together at an important moment for a
long time the scientific community has
told the world that the climate is
changing posing an incredible threat to
us all in recent years we've seen that
the predictions have become reality the
12 hottest years on record have been in
the last 15 it feels like the storms
that used to occur every 100 years seem
to come every few years or in the recent
case of Oklahoma City in within ten days
of each other I had a meeting with
Governor Chris Christie of New Jersey a
few weeks ago and he said I don't know
why they call it the hundred year storm
since I've been in office there have
been three of them and I'm not 300 years
old if nothing is done as we've
discussed already the the risk facing
the region in the country will only
continue to grow so that while we know
that we have to cut carbon pollution by
moving to clean energy sources and
cutting our waste we also know that we
need to act now to prepare ourselves for
the effects of the climate that we're
not going to be able to mitigate against
as everyone here in Connecticut realizes
and throughout the entire New England
region know all too well they're not
theoretical future threats these are the
impacts already being felt because of
climate change while working on disaster
recovery at HUD over the past 13 years
I've seen up close just how devastating
the weather-related disasters can be in
places like New Orleans and Tuscaloosa
and Cedar Rapids and New York New Jersey
Connecticut Rhode Island in Pennsylvania
Delaware hurricane Sandy's fury caused
so much destruction throughout the
region damaging or destroying well over
six hundred thousand homes causing
unprecedented loss of power in the
region
size and scope of the damage done by
Sandy was unlike anything many of us in
this region had ever seen before and it
was clear in Washington that
extraordinary support for the region was
going to be required that's why the
president created the hurricane sandy
task force chaired by secretary Donovan
of HUD to bring cabinet level focus on
the work it wasn't just going to be a
FEMA question of getting in and
providing some relief dollars but really
rallying the entire cabinet a divided
Congress ultimately passed a
supplemental appropriation bill of more
than 50 billion dollars thanks to your
delegations tireless work we're very
grateful that we had the opportunity to
work with you so thanks again senator
once the task force was established we
quickly got to work our goals were to
cut red tape to get the assistance where
it was needed and effectively and
ultimately to outline principles to
guide the investment of federal dollars
since we knew that there would be tens
of billions of dollars in supplemental
flow simple dental assistants flowing
through region we wanted to ensure that
the building the rebuilding would be
done right while certainly rebuilding is
a locally driven process to protect our
communities and our investment in them
we knew that it was really going to be
critical to engage in incentivize
communities to rebuild differently in a
more rebuilt in a more resilient manner
putting back what was lost is usually
the drive after a storm there's a
there's a rush to put back exactly what
was lost we see it on the Jersey Shore
in terms of nostalgia we just want to
get there and put it back but really the
better approach is to take a moment and
pause and think about how we can come
back smarter and stronger than before in
order to do that we need to ensure that
science is the foundation of our work we
need to ensure that local decision
makers have the data that they need to
make scientifically sound decisions it
sounds like an obvious common sense for
step but it's not one that the federal
government has led with in recovery from
previous disasters
there are certainly those who ignore
science and deny climate change but when
it comes to building stronger in
communities it's the research that
matters it's the facts that matter it's
the science so the that's why our task
force partnered with the best scientists
across the federal government to empower
local governments businesses and
citizens with the information that they
need in too many communities the
standards for flood risk had not been
updated in years or even decades and
very few of them incorporate future
risks like sea level rise into how they
look at those risks as one CEO who lost
critical facilities during Hurricane
sandy said just tell me how high to
rebuild theirs there's no clear answer
though there there has not been a clear
answer from the federal government
between confusion on on FEMA maps and
just a lack of understanding about sea
level rise so we set out to answer the
question of how high do we rebuild and
ultimately issued a rebuilding strategy
to the president last month with 69
recommendations which span across the
fields of housing small business
assistance infrastructure investment
data sharing and flood insurance
affordability what makes our report
stand out to other disaster reports is
that it's not just some ideas to sit on
a shelf but rather 69 recommendations
that already have identified owners
across the federal government and
philanthropy and private enterprise one
of the things that we're most proud of
is that through the work of the task
force and Noah we developed a sea level
rise tool perhaps one that will be
useful to Yale going forward as you look
at your own tool to allow local planners
and decision-makers to click on a map
based on address and see a projection
for sea level rise as far as a century
into the future we hope that with that
knowledge and hand communities will take
the measures necessary to protect
themselves from the future floods it's a
Sandy region specific tool but the
presidents Climate Action Plan came out
and called for a similar to a nationwide
perhaps that's something we'll be able
to partner with you
on going forward another initiative of
the task force that we're particularly
excited about is the rebuild by design
design competition we are using a design
competition with philanthropic dollars
from the Rockefeller Foundation and
others to attract innovative design
solutions and ultimately build or
implement resilience projects in
communities in the sandy impacted region
we invited teams of experts to come in
and judge them based on not their design
ideas but the quality of their teams so
we have experts in engineering hydrology
Landscape Architecture many other fields
who came in and responded to our request
for qualifications we received 100 848
applications and selected 10 teams
they're working now in Connecticut New
York New Jersey around the region to try
and partner with think tanks and
universities and really figure out what
are the needs how can we comprehensively
address them with the goal that they
will ultimately tie into the billions of
dollars in federal assistance so that
when the rebuilding happens we'll be
using the best science in making the
best decisions as I close I just want to
stress that the work of the president's
Task Force isn't about looking backwards
it's about looking forward to the next
storm but it's also about a fundamental
shift in the way that communities think
about all the rebuilding that we do all
the building and all the planning should
be incorporating the risk that we face
because of climate change we have
learned through disaster recovery
analysis that for every dollar we spend
on mitigation we can see a four dollar
return when the next storm hits so
there's a lot of economic sense for
investing in mitigation on the front end
it's critical that we protect our
businesses so that we can compete and
continue operating after a storm so I
just like to say thank you again for all
of your work it's exciting to hear all
the work that's going on and I know that
working together we can ready our
communities
you